attention les résultats sont tombés
malades
voilà là
[Applaudissements]
bon
c'est parti ça va ça va
c'est mon dada place on a la place à
l'est les séries alors je vais aller au
public toi comment tu t'appelles cécile
cécile tu fais quoi dans la vie
infirmière en fosse c'est parti la belle
julie tu fais quoi dans la vie
le scandale comptable on en fait pas
tout en tout les trois ça damphousse
aussi en hausse
en face aux fausses infos ça on y va
[Applaudissements]
enfin
j'y reviens l'échelle on va faire un
truc
tout en toi tu es là enfance
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous chantez joly co organisent un petit
coucou relance mais tu es mon ami
bon c est ce que tu penses tu va lancer
dans la musique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pascal
m
j'ai pris une grande décision publique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est le premier chef
[Applaudissements]
nous attestons l'assisteur direct on
pouvait pour sert de tps cas où nachos
et à toulouse
on vous entend pas eu la prescience
et son copain
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je n'accepterai pas ce public une minute
de plus bon l'échec est 6 fois son chéri
de mme barry terme pas vient me parler
mon chéri voyez que jean paul gaultier
talent et moins cher et c'est pas cool
non c'est la fête que tu pars tu as
chanté avec nous ça fait 12 ans qu'on se
connaît que la fia va être embrapa du
bacon rapide à la série sachez connaît
en traiter avec tes clopes et coach
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
obama
beaucoup
attention vous votez chez vous si on
passe sur cette chanson si vous dites
oui j'irai chercher dans la rue moi même
des gens pour participer à ces fêtes et
je veux que tous les gens qui habitent à
côté du sud viennent nous voir
[Applaudissements]
foot gp les impôts c'est parti
kenji andalouse musique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
danser sur des airs de guitare et puis
tu vois tes cheveux noirs des lèvres
rouge tu te balance me reste n'a pas
d'importance que moi
je veux vous
tu m'as
le sud est
je
[Applaudissements]
je perds le dangereux
[Musique]
c'est peut-être
à
[Applaudissements]
dans le monde
[Musique]
montrer
m
j'ai déjà mes pensées se bousculent
comme la lumière
il n'y a que toi qui m'éclate dans la
voix
le chaud et le froid jeté dans la gauche
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]